I know it's the question who watches the
Watchmen but my question is is it worth
it anymore
so I want to talk about the possibility
that HBO is going to do a series whether
it is a miniseries whether they do
multiple seasons of it based on Watchmen
now this is not new news this I didn't
talk about this on the news first broke
that this is something that they are
exploring and developing so why talk
about it now well I didn't talk about it
at the time because they just kind of
shrugged it off I basically thought well
that's what they should have done in the
first place instead of the movie and
kind of moved on from it but
unfortunately the more I thought about
the more like I'm not sure if this is a
good idea either and I had an experience
recently that kind of that gives me a
point of reference to be able to
solidify it better before I get into
that I I'm going to touch on the Zack
Snyder director watch my movie very
briefly I could very easily dedicate an
entire video as to why I don't think
that movie works despite staying
incredibly true to the source of
material but I'm not going to get into
all that if people really want to hear
me dissect why Watchmen as the film
doesn't work I'd be happy to do so but
that's not why I'm here today so the
thing is doing Watchmen as a TV series
whether it is a miniseries or multiple
seasons would have been a much better
way to do it because that sort of
episode by episode sequential
storytelling hues closer to what the
comic book is and the reason I think
that's important is because Alan Moore
is a writer really takes advantage of
what works in comic books and those are
things that don't necessarily work in
other mediums especially the further
away you get from it in the case of
Watchmen specifically I'll just single
this out real quick the comic book if
you read it as a graphic novel it's not
quite the same but you got to remember
this was released in monthly issues now
because you have that break you get each
issue you get you've got a month from
one that comes out until the next one
comes out to digest everything you got I
mean that's
my watchman is so dense you actually was
actually going to be worth it for you to
keep coming back to this thing over the
course of a month until the next station
came out but also because each issue is
closed off it allowed each issue to
delve into something very specific
whether it was the history of the
Minutemen whether it was Rorschach's
mental state whether it was the origin
of dr. Manhattan and just zero in on
that and only deal with that film
doesn't really work like that
don't you really kind of need more of a
through-line for it to work I I don't
they need that like it's an absolute but
that's what film does well film does
does essentially focus forward momentum
very well and that's not watchman but
sort of being able to do it as episodes
you know closed off the way that the
issues are closed off that is closer to
it and would allow you to have honoring
the source material actually work
because as I said the movie was very
true to the source material in terms of
recreating the imagery and using the
same words but because it was so
tailored to that original medium it just
it loses its strength now unfortunately
I think we've hit a point now even
though a miniseries or TV series is what
they should have done in the first place
I actually think it's now not worth
doing it because the movie has already
come out again not because oh the movie
did as well as it can do it but because
because the movie is so accurate to the
original comics in terms of you know
what it presents up there
even though I feel it doesn't work all
you can do is basically present the same
thing Zack Snyder already presented but
just do it in a format that is more
appropriate because it really is so
direct the visual point of reference the
story point of reference the character
references were translated so directly
you know improving the narrative I don't
think is going to be enough because
we're going to be showing going yeah I
saw this maybe this is a little better
but I'm getting the same thing again and
I feel like the movie kind of I feel
like we it was going to be that accurate
we were only going to get one shot at it
and the
movie was the shy and again I personally
don't think it worked because this isn't
a case where the movie happened and it
got everything wrong so we're going to
do the miniseries that do it right which
was the theory behind something like say
Stephen King's The Shining miniseries
now that's not me saying the shining is
better than the movie but that's me say
there was a validity in that because so
much was changed up in the movie version
that Stephen King said no let's do
something that's much more accurate and
so you know they were able to do that
now the obvious solution to that would
be to change stuff so that it makes it
worth revisiting again but Watchmen
doesn't hold up to that B and part of
what got me started thinking about this
again was actually seeing spider-man
homecoming because I said in my review
that I liked all of the changes that
were done to specific characters to some
of the Lord to Peter himself and his
home situation and everything I liked
pretty much all the changes and part of
the reason I like the changes was
because with Sam Raimi's movie it his
first two movies at least we got really
comic accurate representation of these
characters Arlene you know sort of their
initial 60s early 70s versions of these
characters it was incredibly comic
accurate to those in terms of how Peter
behaved how Flash behaves Mary Jane Aunt
May Uncle Ben the Green Goblin Harry all
of it it felt like it was lifted
directly out of the books and visually
it felt a lot like that too
so since we already had our super comic
accurate version of spider-man I was
actually quite relieved and engaged to
see spider-man home company a home home
company I think I said that in my review
to homecoming play with these elements a
little bit more and do something a
little more different with them and
that's the sort of thing I would have
resisted if spider-man homecoming was
the first movie version of spider-man we
had
I wouldn't have been accepting of those
changes because I would have been like
well can't we get you know the accurate
version first well since we did now
there's fine now you'd think that would
mean I'd be going well with Watchmen now
do a more looser version you'll have the
freedom to do that except is a big
difference between Watchmen and
spider-man and that is Spiderman had
decades got about fifty years about of
history to him in terms of you know
stories and characters and ways the the
main character has been interpreted and
things that have happened to him so
there's a lot to pull from and because
it's changed so much it's hardly even
said that there is a definitive version
of spider-man and like I said even Sam
Raimi's version was definitive to a -
you know the version OHSO having he grew
up reading but that's not the case with
Watchmen there is a definitive watchman
there's only one watchman story yes I
know they made the extra stuff before
Watchmen but are any of us really
bringing that on board
really I suppose that Oh HBO could bring
that in for additional material I don't
think that's worth doing but again my
point is Watchmen for as long as it's
been out is just the one narrative you
don't have the freedom to go oh well see
well back when we did it last time it
was that bill and that will do this
other villain that wasn't in the last no
it's the same story and it has to be the
same story because it's not the same
story that it's not Watchmen anymore
anymore Watchmen is not just a thematic
sir it is a meticulous story down to the
fine details everything in that book
means something feeds into something and
is there for a reason
now that's not me saying absolutely
every detail has to be recreated but it
does mean that you cannot just
willy-nilly start changing stuff because
everything matters every brick in this
building matters you start poking at
something the whole thing could easily
come down
everything in that book is a
load-bearing brick which probably isn't
a thing I don't know construction but I
hope you get what I'm saying there and
if you can't differentiate it from the
movie it's going to not feel like it's
an endeavor worth taking but to
differentiate it from the movie is it's
just going to wreck it is just going to
the things that they would have to do to
make it different from the movie would
just not would most likely make the
story not work anymore because I mean
just to be blunt about it no matter who
they get to make this thing and I
believe it's Damon Lindelof working on
it um Damon Lindelof I you sir are not
Alan Moore um if you're going to go in
and try and add new material and make it
seem like Alan Moore it's not going to
work you want to our recent comparison
for that look at the additional stuff
that was written for the look for the
animated version of The Killing Joke you
can tell you can draw a hard line
between the stuff that was written by
other people on namely Brian Azzarello
and the stuff that was lifted directly
from the comic ie essentially written by
Alan Moore huge staggering difference
Alan Moore who it sounds like I worship
at the altar of Alan Moore Alan Moore is
not a flawless person he's not even a
flawless writer but he's an incredibly
good writer and when he is on he's kind
of unimpeachable and he was definitely
on when he wrote Watchmen so if you
can't change it but the movie version we
already got which was widely seen I mean
I know it underperformed - what the
Warner Brothers had hoped but a lot of
people know it certainly the fans all
know it and we've already gotten it and
that you know retained everything and
made it look like Washington sound like
Watchmen what the mini fear is going to
do just add in more details but it's
just going to be
it's just going to be the same thing
longer again it's going to feel like the
super extended cut of the movie now
maybe there's another angle that they
can take with that but again it Watchmen
is not a story that lends itself to I've
got a new spin on this a lot of comic
books are super your comic books
especially anything long-running there's
a ton of room to reinterpret go in there
give it your own spin not Watchmen
though it's just it's it is a singular
work it really is and I think it's an
amazing piece of work and if the movie
had never been made I would be so
cautiously pumped for the idea of an HBO
series but the movie happened and the
movie happened
visually superficially very accurate to
the comic and I think that makes it
impossible now to make a TV version
that's going to be worth seeing because
it's either going to feel like the same
thing again or it's not going to feel
like Watchmen so there's me doing that
thing I often do which is uh to just say
why something that other people are
getting excited about it's probably
gonna suck I don't mean to be this
negative I really don't
it's what my brain does and sometimes I
spell that out and you folks get it
sorry
in any Katie says my thoughts on the
possibility of Watchmen becoming a TV
series on HBO what are your thoughts on
it and exactly what way do you think I
am a massive idiot if you can do so
without wishing death upon me or wit or
any other bodily harm go ahead and leave
your comments down below let's talk
about it don't forget to like subscribe
check me out on Twitter at council of
geeks give a listen to the council of
geeks podcast available on itunes
stitcher i am also one half of the punch
like a girl podcast also available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]